I just spent way too much money on the
Vision Pro and I am already starting to
regret it I will explain exactly why and
if you are looking to buy one I'm going
to give you guys some helpful tips on
how not to go bankrupt while also not
making the wrong choice pre-order
started at 5:00 a.m. this morning and
thankfully everything went smoothly I'm
able to pick one up right away but the
crazy thing is the delivery date is
already in March so I guess people are
buying these now you do have to have a
face ID device in order to scan your
face if you order on your Mac it can
actually send a QR code to your iPhone
so don't think you have to use it and
one positive is that if you only need
readers the price for the Zeiss Optics
are actually 99 bucks I think that's the
only thing that got better and if you're
worried about face ID getting the right
size fit I actually have done this three
different times and each time it was
very accurate we had a medium Loop band
with a medium light seal with 21w for
the sizing so it seems very accurate and
after you get through all of those steps
you can finally see the price now a lot
of people were outraged about that
$3,500 price tag and it is pretty crazy
but it gets worse and unlike a lot of
people I am not planning to return this
device buy it test it out and send it
back and now that I ordered mine I'm
just kind of blown away and I think Tim
Cook expected that because unlike every
other product launch they did not show
us the full pricing until 5:00 a.m. and
now I know why here you guys could see
at the base you get 256 gigs of storage
and if you want to upgrade you can to
512 but it costs you
$3,700 and if you want a one tbyte you
get
$3,900 for that starting price tag now
Apple always ripped people off with
Storage storage prices have plummeted
and they're still charging you 400 extra
bucks now personally I ordered the 512
because what you need to know is that
with all of the M2 M2 Pro M2 Max devices
the base storage is actually about half
the speed compared to the upgraded one
so you're not only paying for that
upgrade to get double the storage but
you're also you know paying for better
speed potentially faster lad times and
unlike a Macbook you cannot just pop in
an external SSD easily um what are you
going to do strap that to the back of
your head I don't know I don't even
think it's going to be possible so I
would say at least spend
$33,700 starting out and honestly I wish
I went for one tab cuz you're spending
so much money now that you know what is
an extra 200 bucks especially for a
device that you cannot upgrade or change
it's locked in next you get to choose if
you want to pay for it in full or use
financing and look at that 325 bucks a
month that used to be a car payment I do
think a lot of people are going to
finance it because that's a ton of money
to do but let's just keep going here and
this is my next shocker Apple Care for
this device is
$500 that is insan insane you could
literally be buying an over $112,000 Mac
Pro and for that Apple Care is500 bucks
for 3 years and they will literally come
out to your house or your office to work
on the machine for that price tag so I'm
guessing that with the Vision Pro they
are not going to be fixing anything if
you break it they just give you a new
one so please be careful with them and
that gets me to the next part if you
want to get a case to protect this thing
which Apple has this interesting looking
case with this little uh soft cover that
looks almost like one of those puffer
jackets this thing looks pretty Sleek
but it's very minimalistic guess how
much this case costs guess comment down
below this thing is
$200 oh my goodness I cannot believe
that 200 bucks for a little case now
this seems like the Vision Pro is
Apple's Rolls-Royce where every single
thing is a $5,000 upcharge which is
relatively the same compared to the
original price tag with this case so if
you pick one of those up you're already
over four grand plus taxes on top now I
have to add please don't waste 200 bucks
on that case check this one out right
here this is made by span a very high
quality uh accessories manufacturer and
look at this thing we have a nice hard
shell with this handle double zippers
different storage compartments and
little things that will hold your cables
this beautiful cushion that will keep
your Vision Pro safe check that out
right there I mean this thing looks
excellent you have a little another
compartment on the inside a little air
tag holder and you can get all of this
for 89 bucks less than half the price
I'll link it down below now of course
this thing only comes with one battery
and the battery life well it ain't very
good because you get up to 2 hours of
General use battery life and 2 and 1/2
hours of video playback now keep it mind
this has up to 2 hours which we know
what that means if you're doing anything
serious it's going to be worse and
there's movies a lot of them that are 3
hours long so if you want to buy another
one it's going to cost you another
[Music]
$200 and how can you just have one of
those batteries that just sounds crazy
so now you're looking to spend even more
money I don't know why this thing is so
expensive because you can get the best
portable battery pack that can fast
charge MacBook Pros for less than that
and it has way more capacity with the
display multiple outputs uh this thing
is amazing for everything I'll go ahead
and Link it down below now I do have to
point something out if you guys take a
look here this has a USB type-c input
for charging it but the benefit is
thankfully it does give you pass through
charging so if you plug in to a wall or
another battery pack like this you can
actually run it all day and it will pass
that through now Apple does call this
the Pro battery and honestly I just
think it's marketing because you're
already spending so much you probably
should spend SP another 200 bucks and
order one of these but if you don't want
to get ripped off pick up one of those
batteries linked below and just pass
through this original one and to make
matters worse if you want a way to clip
this battery to your belt or to
something else that's another 50 bucks
for this minimalistic clip that can hold
it you can just toss it in your pocket
use some tape I don't know hopefully
there's going to be other Solutions but
for now you are buying a $50 clip and
now let's look at our grand total we
have an extra battery here we have the
Apple Vision Pro with the Apple care
because you're probably going to break
it if you pick up one of the cases in
that battery holder you are looking at
5,282 bucks almost
5,300 and then if you have uh
prescription glasses add on another 150
bucks or 170 with taxes man this is a
$5,500 device if you're going to be
wanting to use it for a long time so
please follow my
recommendations uh go get your
accessories down using the links below
so you don't have to spend as much money
if you're buying it let me know your
thoughts has Tim Cook gone crazy and
make sure you guys subscribe because we
have some really killer videos coming
out
he